they're calling this the people's war
here in northern kiev weapons are being
given out to any ukrainian
who can fight
ordinary citizens arming themselves to
defend their country from russian ground
troops marching on the capitol
but not everyone can
or wants to stay and fight
[Applause]
gunshots to control crowds
fighting for trains that struggle to
carry the mass exodus of desperate
residents
trying to flee this conflict while they
still can
the russian bombardment has caused
devastation in this city
forcing terrified residents to spend
last night in underground shelters
my mom and
me
we spent like
almost 12 hours in the underground
together with other people from around
the area
um
actually when you're not alone at home
sitting lonely before in front of
the tv it's much easier you know just to
get along
the threat to ukrainian life is all
around these pictures show a civilian
car being run over by a military vehicle
incredibly the driver of the crushed car
was pulled from the wreckage
still alive
there is utter desperation here
as ukrainian forces battle against
russian troops
ordinary civilians risked their own
lives to slow down the russian advance
this man escaped with his life as he
stood alone in the path of what's
believed to be a russian military convoy
here where the black plumes of smoke can
be seen is thought to be hostile airport
just outside of kiev
russia now claims to have taken over the
site
ukraine's president has been regularly
updating his citizens about the war
this evening he posted a defiant video
saying he was still in the country and
ready to defend ukraine
good evening everyone
the leader of the party is here
the head of the president's office is
here the prime minister mahal is here
president paul diak
our citizens are here we are all here
defending our independence our country
and this is how it will continue
glory to our defenders glory to ukraine
glory to heroes
but the language from moscow showing no
sign of any de-escalation
i would like once again to address the
ukrainians
use them as human shields
it will make it so much easier to talk
to you and to negotiate with you than
with this gang
of nazis that has captured
russia has launched attacks on multiple
fronts and it is clear that this is far
more than a defensive operation
[Music]
the consequences are already being felt
across european borders among the first
refugees of this conflict seeking safety
have started to arrive in romania
we want to leave
ukraine right now but
i think that there is no possibility for
men to leave
so we need to decide have a
five-year-old kid and they have also my
sister who has two kids so we are really
scared and don't know what will happen
here
these people may have found sanctuary
from war but they know their lives and
loved ones remain behind
arches josh's sky news